[Musique]
chaque année le Congrès des mers c'est
un moment attendu des élus locaux c'est
l'occasion à la fois de chercher de
nouvelles idées d'être dans une logique
d'innovation publique et puis en
visitant les institutions ici au Sénat
on rencontre nos sénateurs ça nous
permet d'échanger de façon plus précise
c'est aussi la richesse de ces salons
qui permet voilà de la rencontre d'élus
du département mais qu'on ne côtoie pas
ce qui sont pas dans notre communauté de
communes ou autre c'était vraiment
l'occasion de les voir dans leur lieu de
travail parce qu'ils viennent plus
souvent nous voir nous dans nos lieux de
fonction j'espère bien pouvoir porter
nos problématiques et pouvoir les
résoudre c'est surtout ça
[Musique]
nous sommes aussi une assemblée
politique et donc étant une assemblée
politique nous débattons de la nation
dans un débat parfois contradictoire et
peut-être qu'il y a une ligne d'horizon
c'est la ligne de la capacité à la fois
le dialoguer ensemble de se respecter et
d'avoir pour fil l'intérêt supérieur du
pays
ah ben moi je connaissais pas je
connaissais l'extérieur mais pas
l'intérieur c'est gradur il y a dans le
palais deux buste de personnes qui n'ont
pas été sénateurs le buste de Marie
Médicis dans la salle du livre d'or et
le but de leur premier de Belgique
[Musique]